I've got an update for you on a notable
2018 midterm race it is MIT Romney MIT
Romney is the former Massachusetts
governor the former failed presidential
candidate former co-leader of was it
turtle soup or frogs legs or something
both that he was having with Trump at
some restaurant he's running for US
senator from Utah
Trump has endorsed him he needs to
officially become the Republican nominee
for that seat in order to make it to the
general election in November of this
year and he is at least that his first
opportunity failed to secure that
nomination there's actually now going to
be a June primary for the race because
Mitt Romney failed to get even a
plurality of the vote never mind
the 60% that is required to avoid a
primary in Utah State Representative
Mike Kennedy got just over 50% Mitt
Romney got just over 49% and because
neither of them got 60% there are now
there is now a I guess a real primary
has been triggered for a lack of a
better term in June stunning for a
couple of reasons number one is that
Trump endorsement aside Mitt Romney is
way way way more well known than state
Rep Mike Kennedy so that raises
questions about whether there's sort of
resentment in Utah that Romney I mean
yeah he has a house in Utah and he's had
one there for a long time but doesn't
really live there sort of like a showing
up to run kind of situation maybe
triggering some resentment that's one
possibility the other angle is that
Romney does have the endorsements not
only of the president Donald Trump but
also of retiring senator Orrin Hatch
whose seat he's running for and he still
wasn't able to secure the nomination and
when Romney first announced that he was
running he wasn't even expected to have
a serious primary challenger and now he
didn't even get a plurality of the vote
and the question I'm most interested in
is how prominently is Donald Trump gonna
campaign for Romney between now and the
June primary because we know that Trump
only likes winners period Romney failing
to even get a plurality of the vote and
not helpful to Romley
- Romney is that if he wants Trump's
help he over the weekend refused to say
whether he's either even supporting
Donald Trump for re-election in 2020 you
might remember that Donald Trump either
on the day that he was inaugurated or
the day after filed for re-election and
part of it seems to be that that allows
him to continue raising money in a
particular way but he's running for
re-election is the long and short of it
Romney was asked over the weekend so are
you supporting Donald Trump's candidacy
for 2020 and Romney said he's going to
be making that decision further down the
road so what can we take from this well
number one should we deduce that a
Democrat has a chance in Utah no that is
not what this is about I do not see any
path for a Democratic candidate to win a
Senate race in very conservative and
very very Mormon Utah but the signal
here is that number one a trump
endorsement is not a guarantee of a path
not even to victory overall but even to
a path the Republican nomination we saw
that in Alabama and we potentially are
going to see that in Utah that's
interesting and number two seemingly
anything could happen in the midterms
now yeah not a Democrat becoming the
next senator from Utah but seemingly
almost anything could happen and that's
why people need to vote right no matter
what state you're in no matter which
race you're talking about this is going
to be a wacky midterm it is arguably
going to come down to voter turnout and
I guess you could say when voter turnout
is around 50% even less in midterms kind
of all comes down to voter turnout and
no matter where you are don't stay home
as the message I think there are
definitely places where Democrats and
can win but Utah I don't think is one of
those places I know in 2012 when Romney
ran against Obama Romney picked like 72
percent of the vote he won that state by
a larger margin than any other state
it's just not the right place and maybe
he's losing some support now because
there's that Scott Brown effect where
people are saying you're not really from
Utah but I think he will ultimately win
you think that Romney is gonna oh sure
interesting now what I'm wondering I
mean I guess it's going to have to just
be a turnout play right because he
didn't even get it's not like there was
some
third candidate who took a ton of the
vote there was basically 1% or so in
there
split up among people that were not
Kennedy nor Romney so do you think that
voter turnouts just gonna be higher in
the June primary and that it's gonna
disproportionately go to Romney I think
I think the name recognition will help
Romney certainly there are setbacks I
don't think being tied to Trump is a
good thing for him yeah
so he'll want to leave the Trump
endorsement at just that tweet and
nothing more and interesting that he's
leaving a tepid response and saying that
he's not necessarily going to support
Trump for 2020 yeah I think people will
just walk on eggshells through this
entire race but he'll skate through and
we'll no matter what you say about Utah
Mormons and either one of us could say
many many things very very concerning
things what you can say and we saw this
evidenced by the Utah numbers in the
2016 presidential election Utah Mormons
don't love the Trump thing and even
McMullan getting significant support in
Utah in 2016 and so having clearly in
Utah more than in many other states just
having a Trump endorsement is not a path
to victory even in the Republican
primary the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad